un mandat d'arrêt a été émis contre le
rappeur Maes par la justice française
voici pourquoi alors en fait ce mandat
il est lié à une affaire qui date d'il y
a plusieurs années en septembre 2018
Maes aurait assiné des coups de PO au
visage d'un homme à la sortie d'un
studio parisien entraînant 6 jours
d'interruption totale de travail le
rappeur a indemnisé la victime qui a
retiré sa plainte la justice a cependant
décidé de poursuivre Maes pour violence
en réunion c'est donc pour ces fait que
wallyid Georget de son vrai nom devait
se présenter le 10 octobre 2023 au
tribunal correctionnel de Paris mais
Maes qui vit à Dubaï n'est finalement
pas venu pour des raisons
professionnelles selon son avocate le
rappeur avait un showcase le 9 octobre à
Dubaï en plus de ce concert Maes aurait
planifié des journées d'enregistrement
en studio toute la semaine le président
de la 13e chambre correctionnelle
interrogé par l'AFP estime que ses
excuses ne sont pas valables la
procureure a elle déclaré on ne loue pas
un studio le jour où on doit comparaître
devant un tribunal il savait que sa
présence était indispensable l'avocate
de Maes indique que le rappeur n'a pas
fui ses responsabilités selon elle le
rappeur avait le droit d'être représenté
à son procès et l'affaire pouvait être
jugée en son absence le procès a
finalement été renvoyé au 5 juin 2022